in the lobby of Ramsey solution Stephens
with us hey Steven welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show how's it going Dave better
than I deserve man where do you live
Austin Texas cool welcome to Nashville
and all the way up here to do a
debt-free scream yes sir very cool
that's how much have you paid off
seventy five thousand in four years
seventy five thousand in four years and
your range of income during that time
starting at 20 and about a hundred now
Wow nice jump what do you do for a
living a full-time personal trainer okay
cool and what kind of debt was a seventy
five thousand oh man student loans
mainly engagement ring
oral surgery credit card motorcycle Wow
yeah an engagement ring you borrowed on
but she's not here when are you getting
married of we married end divorce within
three months oh yeah ouch sorry I
brought it up yeah yeah well you said
engagement ring you opened the door yeah
Wow okay so what kind of so I would say
motorcycle engagement ring what else
student loans student loans okay what uh
oral surgery oral surgery okay Wow yeah
a little bit of everything here okay
cool and four years from twenty thousand
a hundred thousand so tell me your story
tell me what happened four years ago
summer of 2014 I was staying with my
buddy sledge who's my small group leader
and a big cheerleader during the process
he showed me a youtube video of you live
in Dallas many years ago doing the whole
baby steps outline and I'll never forget
when you were talking about how bubbles
is to deliver yourself from the hand of
the hunter and the the imagery of the
cheetah and I remember you screaming the
top of your lungs to run as fast as you
can because the thing was to eat you and
and I just I got I got super emotional
and it was the first time I felt no
one's ever told me how serious this was
and that I could do it and it was the
first time I felt hope cool
cool yeah so that got you in gear you
decide to get out of death and tell me
what happened well mine Kim was super
tiny I was in college I was just
starting to do personal training and I
just you know i clogged along I got rid
of driver distance amount and small ones
first got out of the collection process
and then I feel like it wasn't too long
I was uh I was up to my student loans
was the big pile and three years ago as
of this past Friday I was on my way home
a moment on my motorcycle and I was
t-boned by a drunk driver on my
motorcycle and I lost my right foot and
you know it was kind of a you know time
to really refocus and took a hard look
at my life you know and just got really
serious and yeah Wow so there's a period
of this four years when you didn't pay
off any debt because you were
convalescing you were getting used to
prosthetic leg your rehab you know
you're grieving you're rehabbing your
mind and your body right yeah I mean I
how long were you down maybe a year no I
was walking in two months and I'm a been
a power lifter for 15 years and that was
a big goal is to get back into the gym
and four months after I lost my foot I
was dead lifting over 400 pounds again
oh and and yeah it was just like you
know how how close can I get to those
numbers I used to hit and a year after
that I was dead lifting 500 and
competing and strongman competitions
against non amputees and placing and
going to Nationals and just yeah just
like I was just on fire about like how
much I could accomplish with I'm missing
limb you know wow that's rowdy rowdy man
good for you
thank you good for you so it makes the
story extra poignant yeah it's cool to
win a strongman competition it's really
cool to win it against non amputees
right yeah that was Dells wild I was I
knew I was pretty pretty strong going
into it but it was it was surreal you
know it was like
yeah the quote that meant a lot to me
through this is a Viktor Frankl who
survived the Nazi death camps and says
uh you can take everything from a man
but one thing the last of the human
freedoms to choose your attitude in any
given circumstance
search for meaning let's add a book yeah
it's a good book
oh wow very good cool okay so man this
is that's inspiring for an amazing story
after the actual accident how long was
your pity party it was uh it was
intermittent but I mean maybe maybe a
few months of you know the worst part
was going from fairly busy to I'm
staying at my mom's can't go anywhere in
the day my driving foots gone so I'm
just like I can't go anywhere except
some friends texting me around good
friends of mine helped me get around but
for the most part I had all this
downtime to think about it I was doing a
lot of pain that the drugs were awful
and there was you know those a lot of
time to think about things and I joke a
little time between reading good books
and and so how long did you take off on
your get out of debt thing because
obviously accident you push pause and
and you focus on recovery from the
accident and then at some point you
pushed play again on your get out of
debt so what was the gap so I had this
small so the guy was an uninsured but I
had this small uninsured motorist tack
on to my motorcycle insurance and that
gave me about eighteen thousand to like
it was a little more than that but I
used some of it to pay for medical stuff
and then there was an eighteen thousand
left over where I was like huh you know
how awful these student loans and so I
just I threw out all that at it so
really it was as soon as I got that
check you know game on through that
right on there and then the people at
the gym I worked at we're training my
clients while I was down he and I was
still being paid Wow yeah they they did
a power lifting meet fundraiser and
an envelope full of cash and and so it
didn't really stop much you know that
that really actually increased it a bit
just that that insurance check and the
money they gave me and go fund me that
my mom set up and and so it you know
probably about twenty thousand dollars
accelerated it and then business picked
up you know between then and now
business has picked up massively and so
it I mean that's really when it
accelerated mm-hm you know you've got a
great story to tell to take on clients
yes sir and so it's uh having a
testimony is a wonderful thing getting
ones a pain in the butt yeah so well
done man very well done you have you're
an overcomer without a doubt so we know
where the motorcycle went it got sold
for insurance it was totaled I'm sure a
little bit and the guy had no insurance
huh yeah as a hit-and-run oh you don't
even know where he is well I do I they
caught him and okay last year I've
testified against them and he's going to
prison for eight years but Wow yeah yeah
ouch ouch
well he get him off the road is there oh
my gosh unbelievable Wow so what do you
tell people with this journey this epic
saga you have been on what is the secret
for getting out of debt you have to want
to Dave I mean you have to want to bad
you have to be disgusted and with
yourself and with the situation and
taking ownership of you put yourself
here disgusted with it and you know
became an obsession you know it's like
like nothing is gonna stop me I'm
getting out of debt and I'm just so
ready for the way to be lifted off the
closer I got to the finish line I was
like you know how much can I cut back
and put any extra business I get on top
of the debt and I mean you know as a
trainer I I do it feel like I want the
people so badly to want their goal isn't
to reach them but like you say um you
can lead a horse to water but you can't
make them drink and I can want it for
him and I can give them all the tools
and and unfortunately sometimes they
they don't want it as bad as I wanted
for them and it's it's like I'm sure you
talk to people the same thing they
haven't won a bet enough to decide I'm
doing this
they don't talk long - yeah well done
man
Stephen Austin Texas got a copy of Chris
Hogan's retire our everyday millionaires
book for you you're on the way to being
that what a great story count it down
let's hear your debt free scream three
two one
[Applause]
we love it love it love it man
and you've done an excuse that's uh what
yeah really